hi everyone welcome back to resident
evil it's Saturday November or something
maybe December I'm not sure I can't
really think that far ahead I'm like my
Hardy here at Marrakesh you our names
array I know because you were watching
me do the lower thirds this time I was
watching like a hawk I'm not leaving the
room this time cool Chapter eight
resident kin evil revelations how far
are we didn't you say there was 12
chapters and my nuts do I forget not
nuts there are 12 chapters we probably
get through to today I say we get a
little recast oh yeah I'd forgotten what
happened yeah no there's sexy Santa
remember when you said he looked like
Santa's dick no I said sexy Santa pirate
yeah oh fat snake got your stupid mouth
I wish there was a recap for our
previous episode like what you do for
gravy pop pop race was always really
funny yeah there's actually my favorite
part and it was so short yeah
Wow done that show in a while all right
cool chapter eight on Rails should I say
on water no it's actually not rails
turret section
a little earlier that's specific we're
approaching the Queen Zenobia now
rendezvous with the ship's halt oh my
god it's that girl yeah it is
Jessica declares actually what happens
if one of my legs is told and the other
isn't I like to imagine she tried doing
like a really cool like Michael Jackson
dance where she rips off her pants but
only one leg came off do you hear that
little leather squeal you I did hear
that squeak
she's like god I hope it doesn't go
after the leg that has no coverage oh
did we see that before I've never seen
that before see what this no you didn't
do a spoiler last episode oh I did
these tentacles are so annoying our one
shoots grenades as well I miss
Oh what did you hit those yes oh I
thought they just missed I think I mean
maybe not I tried to hit them with a
rocket I only have four Rockets left
you got to manually heel with your herbs
do I need to heal your bleeding yet
apologies in finance it apologies in
advance if I am tired this episode I
love how her reaction I love our
reaction to them is that they're so
annoying
yeah Jessica you're annoying god they're
so annoying get out of here you big
snaky thing [ __ ] I'm not doing very good
I was up fruitless very Resident Evil 6
to me or 5 maybe 5 5 had this remember
and we hated it
yeah I was on the de jambe I was up
early this morning for Red Dead 2 online
yeah how is it hey it's got some things
to work out it's fun when it works but
then like they need to work out some of
the PvP stuff can you not play like as a
team no you can but um for Falls sakes
what's your help other posses can
can like ambush you during missions so
and you can do the same to them but then
once you start fighting them
[ __ ] you respawn like right away I'm out
I'm overheating
that's my last heel I'm stress-eating
get on Zenobia the wadiya
Zenobia was a little de novia joke it's
weird
well this looks like a good spot what
the [ __ ]
tape just like hyper-sexualized her as
much as possible she gets such little
screen time but they're like make sure
she's tying her shoe yes in doing a
stretch hey it's hunk you get one line
in a film but you're like oh these tits
my bra became unhooked again ooh whoops
my voluptuous acid store
[Laughter]
how was it able to float around the
Mediterranean undetected it wasn't magic
well that was my first guess why did all
traces of velcro vanish after the Tara
Grigio panic probably got blown oh god
he's not an attractive man
third why is someone trying to use the
rikiya solace to destroy this an obeah
the answer to these questions will lead
you to an inconvenient truth
[Music]
I like that good we did it
oh it's the leg lady why did you fire to
protect our people or was she protecting
information the revelation of ldraw sir
I've been shot in the head just give me
a minute
I think that leading does he have a
boner is a double-crosser that's what
happens when you die that was a quick
chapter a boner so chapter 9 here we go
um I think that lady's a double-crosser
yeah me too
cuz like there was no value in shooting
him at that point
no she's protecting our people Oh check
this out I'm balancing ok the camera can
see that no they can't um speaking of it
was nothing other chapter just that
checkpoint it said it was the end of the
chapter
did it say you're like chapter 9 now no
it didn't cuz you know like the chapters
are divided into yeah some chapters been
on a ship before what the [ __ ] she's
just holding on to him this woman's
hysterical maybe you should get off the
ship fat snake you should toss you
overboard we need to lose weight and
fast why are you guys all looking to
shoot him in the head
SEC don't look at me I only have one
pant leg on that saves like at least
four ounces like even her headpiece is
weird because her hair is sticking out
of it there's nothing practical about
her which is fine all Ramon's doing
half the story I'm not going okay is
that through remember when I
accidentally okay so I want to go
through this wall right no where do I
want to go down so you want go down I
want to go down tried to trick me like
so what's in here Oh Christopher
together no cuz that's stairs or is this
don't you wanna go to but on the ladder
they're both down that's why it's
misleading damn
where is that
am I in danger
okay am I supposed to check your map
again
go downstairs yeah I guess I need to
swim this is another swimming level damn
it
oh wait no no no what did I do it wrong
I did it wrong twister own wait no come
on bring the backups backup okay
oh no you're right yeah you're good you
just you do have to swim yeah and then
up the other ladder
yeah yeah
um go okay Oh watch out for the veggie
juice it's I like your restraint for not
using a grenade once thank you
I might need those holy guacamole
no gene Oh trust me I've done this
before Chris careful the water is
infested with infected so you could say
it's a defective okay looks like you're
going down go G juice where am I going
I don't know all right let's check the
old map berry' no I'll keep going so go
down to the bottom yeah but there are
two exits in the bottom so be careful
there's quicksand ah I showed you the
old prospector [ __ ] it's following me
I'm really having trouble controlling
everything I gotta say this is not going
well for Mary Rock there's like a
hundred where my god Oh get air first
all the way up
oh this level is fun
yep there's a lot of fun it's really
hard to controller I'm making fun of the
game not you you're going to the bottom
left corner so here no no on the map
bottom left yeah okay I got it
alright let's try this again holy [ __ ]
that was so annoying
Oh for [ __ ] sake
alright I'm just gonna get more air cuz
I've already dealt with this [ __ ] get
away from me fat XIV that's Chris oh my
bubby fat snake okay I okay
underwater oh my god this is
insufferable
no no wait yeah I think yeah
my god yeah thank you card thank god
there's a vagina in here I can feel it I
can that's a good someone needs to make
a shirt of that quo I can feel it oh no
get that god bless you
there's some error right near you good
because I need it yeah where it's you're
right about that light get out of my way
god those things up underwater levels
saw everything sucks it's always really
nice when the game can actually make
water levels fun like Rayman Origins i
remmber had really good water class yeah
I remember Rayman in that Ori and the
blind forest balls you're all 2d games
oh [ __ ] Mario 64 for his craze that
game is his water levels
to control
what's going on
why is Chris bleeding now I don't know
maybe he was like you're obviously
struggling you're pretty [ __ ] at this so
I'm gonna take over wait am I supposed
to still follow him
yeah the boxes were blocking off
where is he is it in here in the store
yeah that's like the only way I can go
it has to be I just thought he would
have waited for me you know
well rude
yes
nope the ladder this was when Capcom
just started to figure out that
following someone was Jill easier so the
same button for dive is climbed the
ladder so like this was bound to be on
the Semiramis cool what way this way why
didn't he just open the door I don't
know I'm so confused
well that door is like high tech or
something right in your friggin eye here
- I don't feel it should I use the
elevator and typical resonable game
going - I'm gonna do a laboratory it
reminds me the lab where that Rachel
woman was are you time with the booth
woman that I shot it yeah okay
I remember that like it was yesterday
this is a good scanning area I feel
hopefully everybody's Thanksgiving was
nice we had a good Thanksgiving let's
talk about it what happened we it's
Super Mario Party uh played jack box
had some food yes we had Turkey you
brought beer and wine it was like you
knew that you couldn't cook so you
brought beer in wine can you cook I can
but I just like chose not to yeah well
every L said their brain stuff was like
ol knowing our group we're gonna run out
of alcohol which we kind of did we did I
drank the rest of your wine so after we
had a lovely Thanksgiving I'm not sure
what I'm supposed to be doing
[Music]
some sort of surfer is it something else
what else am I missing here I'm just
gonna leave ya so after we ate dinner
we played Mario Party and my favorite
part was you won the first game you won
the first game and then we played
another game and sorry does the belt
rail card not work on that it says it
needs finger prints yeah so I gotta find
this guy's finger in this room maybe
there you go right listen I can't get it
shut up do something with that computer
it looks like it doesn't it
well don't scan it go off in traffic
you're thinking too hard anyway so we
did the second Mario Party and we were
playing a minigame where you had to like
do this really fast and everyone's
freaking out and we someone and we don't
know exited out of the game and then
close the game we gave it we just ended
up saying whoever was in first one
because I think it was on our bags yeah
he said never want to mario party game
before yeah well she won he would have
it she deserved to win we acknowledged
that she was the winner yeah and then
did we play something else
we played jack box 5 yeah we
we played the robot rap battle
okay so Lucy was gonna win I think the
Mario Party second and then omurice one
robot rap battle by a lot oh no I read
those sorry
thus karma gleeg lon
Skaar m'g Leone squirming Leone
oh no the DNA of a shark it's gonna
happen again what was the first the
first game was remade where you saw them
in that tank frontal defenses full
frontal defenses
is this thing filled with water cuz I
don't want to be in here no I actually
don't want to be in here Oh balls
awesome he gets his head shot
[Music]
yeah
[ __ ] you what are you
have you got that 180 turn oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh god I should have left shouldn't I
have okay that wasn't that wasn't great
Oh Christmas here yeah didn't go great
Burberry Chris killin no no no no he has
a little jumping animation
well that's not gonna damage him Oh what
is it oh it's a zombie thing oh I guess
so yeah
never mind that cracks like a paper
I want to make sure not to damage this
tank it's really nice
koi fish in there Oh balls get mouthy
its trophies whoa poor fish
check out those spelunkers I used to
fish a lot a lightning Hawk
sounds like a Magnum to me a really cool
[ __ ] name so okay so that's the Magnum
so I'm gonna use this gun because I
don't want to use my Magnum immediately
alright well are we gonna talk about
this or should I just keep going forward
I just keep going forward
oh I see can I replace it'll just send
the other one your weapon box
I just wanted okay it's making me give
up my sniper rifle oh no it's not okay I
did it that's what I wanted I like that
rifle it's just really nice long
distance strike heal that the one on the
ground is your machine gun yes I want my
sniper rifle what you I find it very
helpful I'm gonna heal actually I don't
think it's too late cool hmm so our good
friend Nathan Shepard statistics of the
playthrough this heart ate only one last
episode do not look
I know that's like the number one way to
get something luck how many kills do you
think you have hundred and eighty two
hundred 69 69 43 on last episode alone
what's the Oh a lot of oohs is a lot of
hunters 69 hunters nice sucked on bayous
thirteen times forty seven health
recoveries 177 scans Nathan you're
counting the scans Nathan you're
counting the scam I bet you that's low
considering I didn't know I was supposed
to scan every room until like way too
late in the series I didn't know Nathan
has always hoping a good Thanksgiving
yeah it sounds like a Fire Emblem game
oh that was he absolutely good that's
great
sweet let's do some more you're still
down right yep we got
yeah there's three parts to that Shepard
sixty-seven percent accuracy how'd you
get sixteen percent did you only have
fire a few times I don't know that's not
very good is it sure I think what you
know we're shooting it maybe it was
previously on Resident Evil Revelations
a it's jackass
hey it's me you lovable jacket
everything about the Queen Zenobia and
the secret she keeps
Jessica why did you fire I feel you
didn't say that with enough gusto you
know yeah boy ii could be better kind of
like your first acting thing where it's
like your friends just been shot by your
other friend what do you say and you're
like Mike why did you fire return some
videotapes hmm thank you for at least
answering me Oh what do you think your
revelations so far three-quarters the
way I don't hate it but I would say it
it's on the lower end for me
fair enough it's not even close to
Veronica it's way more on the lines of
like five to me it's kitschy it's silly
it's asking a lot of like weird things
the mechanics are bit off I do not like
the water swimming imagine doing that on
3ds back in the day
I don't like changing characters this
many times I like to kind of have a
focus it doesn't mean it doesn't mean we
can't change a couple times but I don't
want to be jackass we have two
completely different sets of people
we're switching between three yeah no
you're right three it's hard for me to
keep it together I don't like how
they're just throwing waves of enemies
at me instead of just making them seem
more impactful like when I beat like a
hunter that should be a monumental thing
whereas in this game they threw like
that's them 20 hunters at me yet and I
was just like like popping them off if
this doesn't seem as valuable to me that
being said it's way more fun than five
yes yes I think it's like more it kind
of feels like five to me where is this
in the timeframe of when they were
released was this before 5 was released
no no no this came out 2011 or 12 on the
3ds okay doesn't 12 I believe this is on
the 3ds it's originally 3s game yeah
that's why I was saying imagine the
water levels in that
but you had used it it was much much
better the Circle Pad Pro if you ever
use that with you Jack I don't really
know how these dudes fit into no value
this entire story besides comic relief
oh and one time he was like I know how
to stop a a rocket from hitting you you
need to go to this place I've blessed
I've located on your map
Oh jackass like their their comedic
relief yeah you got some built sword
behind that computer he does have dope
swords I've already forgot what he said
that would be tits jackass that is cool
I forgot about the scans the scam I just
think it's it's more impactful if you're
playing like one character maybe because
then you get to know them and you care
about them whereas like in this game I'm
playing so many people like I don't care
about jackass they were trying to
convince me to care about him they did
not do a good job even in resin Evil six
you were playing those two same people
through a whole campaign before you
finished I need a better gun no I want
to figure this out oh he's not that Oh
neither of them were I thought they were
[ __ ] dead boy I really like struggled
to get the right gun in that situation
didn't I it happens oMG Santiago said
this is his favorite resonable game
really yeah well it can be for all sorts
of reasons it can be because it's like
nostalgia it can be like your first it
could genuinely be that you like the
action-packed mists of it I would say
some people would probably compare this
to four in the sense where it's like you
know a lot of like action and just good
timing in general it's just not
personally for me
and again it doesn't mean I dislike it I
would just not put it I wouldn't even
put it close to my top faves it's more
like in the middle Mike man berry sauce
my Hardy opportunity uh so I asked when
you left I was like I can't think of any
all I could think was Mike mashed
potatoes my hearty but now I've thought
of a better one um hold on oh okay
Mike my hard-boiled eggs do people eat
the hard-boiled eggs on Thanksgiving I
thought so yeah that's decent but it
works in your name better Oh deviled
eggs is what people eat and I [ __ ] up
yeah nevermind
boiled eggs that would be tits no longer
well I roar I shall sharpen my claws
Chris W said tips for quick movement
we're running away from or around
enemies never strafe always run forward
okay oh right yeah I've been having a
real hard time dodging yeah it just
seems not confuse like a boss fight it
does there's a lot of [ __ ] in here yeah
it doesn't seem like good things happen
in here
this only has 30 bullets so it's
probably behooves me to keep I'm gonna
keep my heavy stuff for now and if I
need to go back to a regular gun I will
oh I didn't mean to do that what did I
get what did I just do evil instead of
the rifle I had right no you have now
you you swap your shotgun for a rifle
you didn't have a rifle had a machine
gun and an RPG you might have dropped
something for that RPG back there oh I
couldn't like my shotgun yeah what
should i if I given you two RPGs
probably best to take that though maybe
replace the rifle like you're telling me
to take both rocket launchers is that
what you're saying if you try picking
out the other one will just give you an
army so the reason I like the shotgun is
it's extremely helpful to stagger
enemies that are up my ass totally
anyway
in the flesh you take two gadgets like a
flight of horseshit it's just the
computer what did you do quit it's not
me his name is Quinn tower I guess I
would be interesting then I couldn't
even get up here okay you stay here and
spend quality time with your girlfriend
okay some shits gonna go down while he
leaves yeah maybe they're gonna split
you up okay well I have a lot of ammo
and there's a lot there's so many
grenades that here we go I hope this
rusty piece of crap works yay there's so
many grenades and stuff I should just be
I'm planning on being pretty liberal
with them and then look at this there
these barrels that I assume I can blow
[ __ ] up in with this game showing us
anything though it's willing to throw
waves of beat war
okay so this is gonna start the fight is
my guess and it's saved
alright I'm getting up here excuse me oh
my goodness I am having a real hard time
like it's ever since the air was being
really shitty I was heaven I've just
been having a real hard I've been having
a really hard time with just my throat
in general is kind of shitty it's a dog
hopefully doesn't know how to use they
do know how to use the stairs
what what no no nothing nothing you're
jumping sorry it's probably gonna be
good to like just move up and down on
the planes like it's a dog there's smart
oh I didn't mean to do that
count your feet Oh balls
that was a mistake
no it attracted them nice I got a few
all right yes many time you're about to
die just run straight at their face I
mean you've been doing it I'm almost out
oh what's your other weapon machine gun
do I have to turn that back on yeah why
do I need this rocket launcher I
probably help ya climb up and then use
it maybe but like on these guys are you
sure yeah
oh we're not that close that was more a
good warning shot shut up
oh I used it again it actually did not
hurt you that much or at all oh [ __ ] off
where is it in the corner with me Python
well I've used both of my rocket
launchers so hopefully I don't need
those oh yeah go get the generator sorry
I need that Jenny bag
what rifle you're fine
you could put down your shop I guess
that I don't have any shotgun chest so
I'm sorry was I supposed to do something
I think he did it yours waiting for him
or get noscoped oh that was a mistake
bad call
[ __ ] I don't have enough ammo when these
are all close ranged enemies blows I
gotta use the mag now oh [ __ ]
got you got you that was a waste another
one there's so Chuck Palahniuk books so
cry
they're kind of cool Battletoads if
three bullets left in that no balls that
was a mistake nice I think
[ __ ] oh there's a yeah I don't know what
to do I'm a little stressed out
bring your ass oh I did it I'd get down
from here where is I found him okay we
got him oh there was another one oh it's
done get the [ __ ] out of here false Oh
Odin helpful now earlier Bobby's here
that's you oh no
balls music I see them noise
holy now no I'm not ready all right wait
should I like exchange guns again yeah I
think you'll get more hint
cuz that Magnum was baller I don't know
if you'll come across me Magnum ammonia
I know I shouldn't you know I should had
nice didn't want to wait I couldn't hold
those horses any longer you just said
that where's our man
director O'Brian I think I put it all
together
that's mister altro was never back in
action it was all smoke and mirrors
orchestrated by yourself your own little
felt reproduction all to get into the
head of one certain somebody yeah you
pretty much got it I'm glad I'm not
paying you for nothing I analyzed his
log stare and there's something you may
want to see then let me see it yes sir
I'll send it immediately wait why are
you sending him why are you helping him
connection uh-huh we may detect it
just like the boys old days
[Music]
you don't really need to be there to
send the data cluster bomb carpet bomb
sorry I'm out
and now yeah I wasn't sure if they were
trying to help him or hurt him did you
notice that it said error but then it
went green were in behind him in the
very last second it was the next part
like you escaping that place now I don't
know I don't know anything anymore the
virus
are you getting toward the end of a
resonable me when you get into lab oh is
that a sea of red Earth's - hmm I
believe that's the color red we need to
stop the virus from getting out ever
think about how our Reds could be
completely different we never be able to
describe it
you mean like any colors or specifically
red any color what's he pointing at Oh
Chris doesn't dumb after all huh okay so
there isn't one here
oh I left him back there is he okay with
that okay oh but I think I picked the
wrong way yeah you're good just there's
a control panel right there wait that's
to get that's to change the lasers again
because I need to rock
oh you did go that side yeah just go I
see what you're saying I'm sorry no that
turned it off
now Chris is here are all those lasers
off now I think they are yeah on the
other side now okay I see that was
whoever designed this is like very
confusing I almost need to use that herb
thing fingerprint good thing you've ever
said that earlier yeah oh I [ __ ]
don't have a machine gun anymore good
probably right there there's no box to
exchange for your El Hawk is it this guy
yeah hold on to that guy I think that
I don't know why my scanner is being
weird on my way dum-dum great
something onward
[Music]
later later later okay what doesn't
sound good pounding you have an upgraded
weapons in a while no I haven't had a
box malacara
sounds like a desert or like a
Mediterranean dish or like ceramic
soldiers I was gonna say like another
wife of Trump
I'm malacara I came here totally legally
and I married this man for love and
nothing else
yeah let's not open that one again huh
huh I think I understand I was so sure
that's what it was intending
no.6 yeah get a lot of those waste my
life I can't believe you kill more
hunters than a zoos that strike you as
odd yes it does
whew [ __ ] suck unbelievable
wait
the world now to wait for hell it's
already here I'm Bernard corty the ship
has been contaminated
no none of us would betray the Veltro
Norman so essentially they wanted to
bring like hell to earth and then when
it infected the people on the ship they
were like why us
how could this have happened
we're such good people that's great oh
this looks like another one of these
important awesome sites a Google
yes that gold what is a gold upgrade
alright so let's talk about this I have
a shotgun I've really enjoyed having the
sniper rifle but it's not good close
quarters and I have a magnum but the
problem is is my only carrying three gun
sucks because I like having this gun
strictly just chuck away ammo for when I
like don't you know it's not an
important thing
the handgun yeah it's just like a nice
thing to have like pop someone like six
times yeah I keep it so I'm inclined to
get rid of the Magnum and then get it
back when I need it but how aims like a
room you'll need it do you think so I
know you like the rifle but probably
okay fire rate on the Magnum probably
good and it's already gotten that like
what animals not gonna get knocked back
I mean it's fine it's just commit
goodies are probably good know again
that reloader reload her I'm not gonna
reload that much maybe just [ __ ] up
its damage by even more by damage one
sure that's good
all right so then I'll probably switch
this sniper with like a shotgun or
something close range
how does that sound combat shotgun
probably though oh this one yeah I would
say this one needs some upgrades as well
I would definitely put the reloader on
there 40% for one my goodness what's
narrower what does that mean like a less
big of a I like the scatter I would say
keep it what does find as it's done
that that's good fine yeah you're good I
could also take them off my other
shotgun that I'm not using anymore
like this other shotgun has damage and
firing rate yeah because I'm not gonna
use it yeah is that what we've decided
yeah and then we can get better ones on
this bad boy so do we still want damage
or what would be a fire oh you can't
even do fight two on I can you I does
not look like it but I could I could
replace days with damage I could replace
any of these with damage damage too
which i think is pretty days I think
like the shotguns already gonna tase
them that's cool all right so good
and like if I'm in trouble
well balls there was another upgrade up
here if I'm in trouble
I have only have room for 10 magnum
rounds no 18 total
that's just remember that's up here
you'll be moving around anyway in this
room it looks like okay so should I get
rid of my shotgun that or my handgun and
replace it with something more valuable
I don't know like if anything the rifle
but like your machine you don't have
much machine gun it you know I think
you're good
you think the handguns good especially
doesn't do very much but yeah that this
handgun is pretty is better than I
forget what I supposed to be doing so
there's a good timing will do you can
count on it okay
I just don't get my shotgun out okay
something comes through this dough oh
how just like the [ __ ] hot
just remember the fire template ocarina
it's kind of like this oh nice
call the shotgun nice okay
ah behind you like far right yeah you
know what Dad Oh
wait something instinct tells me that
you're gonna have to remember this so
like something's gonna chase you on the
way back probably oh I see okay that's
okay so there's a laser there I mean I
don't know for sure but that just seems
like something this game would do yeah I
agree
okay so I don't want to use my sight
[ __ ] I'm just hurting myself now you're
good with weapons I know I'm good with
weapon oh you mean you don't want to
scam I was trying not to scan so I could
memorize it visually but every time I
try to memorize it visually I hurt
myself significantly so I'm not gonna do
it anymore
oh my god
okay you should be good by now oh no
what changed it wait oh you could go
underwater or something I guess no no no
no no don't press that I think you got
to go back and then still he's still
there like go back there's probably
another switch somewhere so yeah make
your way to that ladder and go into the
water I think
this [ __ ] blow it's all due to be
careful guys why didn't you mention that
thing III what's that noise
that's a as a shield news thing
bow-bow
Jesus
nice
your health is load just so you know I
don't know I thought he was dead yeah
goddamnit I like literally have no help
wait he's still alive are you kidding do
you use your handgun on now I said oh
you have a lot of shotgun shells are you
[ __ ] that's just really honest truly
unbelievable yeah 15 more percent until
you ya see the handguns good yeah it is
good you might get the health from
scanning the dead body now can you do
that yeah I think so yeah I hear it I
hear something Oh another one of them
that's unfortunate I might be worth a
Magnum or just keep [ __ ] up its hand
gun it's pretty good down down down
[Music]
who is that he's electric now what the
[ __ ] he's like an ostrich if it were
mutated oh my god this is really scary
there you go
help it's dead
geez all right hang on I forgot Jill's
handgun it's good I probably have to use
this help honestly yeah geez
I did so bad at that scanning section I
got rid of all my extra health illegal
custom parts what go back that way go
back go back well there's a door down
there okay there's definitely a door
here yeah is that what you meant
oh yeah turn the lasers off maybe or no
now you're know now this is gonna bring
you right to that do with a key car I
think Oh looks like the architects room
and Matrix Reloaded well not really
nevermind I have not seen any of the
matrixes except for the first one it's
completely fine I know handgun nice
machine gun nice
mm oh I needed that
okay we're done feel like I should be
using my Magnum or they're giving me
lots of ammo yeah you have 18 rounds I
can copy the passcode here but I need an
employee number first oh my god do I
need that from something that I read you
can just look through no no no that's a
map that's different you have to come
back here now if you oh my god thinks of
dumb yeah alright so now we're going
backwards right should i inoculate
myself alright so I'm gonna have my
Magnum ready
yeah cuz I'm gonna come back here and
get these bullets anyway
is there any secrets in here no this
thing
that technical thing from outside oh
look some illegal custom parts someone's
been breaking the law
I'm paranoid for good honestly like
almost easier to stay in the scope and
do it first-person whatever all right
there you go five five zero three three
two one did I see that right I don't
it's not gonna make you manually input
it I don't think well say it six times
fast five zero three three two one five
zero three three two one five zero three
three two one five zero three three two
one five zero three three two one five
zero three three two one nice wasn't
that hard at all not like red leather
yellow leather red leather yellow
leather that one's weird um have a toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy
boat toy boat toy boat toy boat toy boat
toy boat to avoid to avoid
there you go
so where am I going he was behind the
attacks on Tara seems like it I have to
go back cuz I can't leave with the
lasers the way they are I hate this room
so [ __ ] much I have to use another
goddamn Health just be cognizant of that
I'm still impressed with you four
immaculately yourself okay
I'll put your arm in go complete I think
it's two different things but that is
funny
so I already did this right yeah do it
again in case yeah same here Jill oh my
god no way
hey what is I don't remember
yeah he'll it's to your right what do
you mean can you scan underwater I know
I can't and like where am I supposed to
go where am I supposed to go just back
to where you came up the elevator were
christened I can't
I flew in a laser block and the lasers
are here you know I'm wait wait wait
wait no no you oh no way I'm gonna
[ __ ] look at them wait no they saved
it I just have to do the thing again
yeah you have to do that why didn't they
save it but right before the water rush
then so that I can see the lasers okay
this is like on purpose so here's what I
want to show you
oh no there's no way back right this one
because it's behind lasers no no there's
another one the other one will get his
keycard first I don't think you got it
I'm saying it pushed you back here no I
think I have it white the objector said
search for a key code it did
no I have it because I'm getting a key
code from that machine when I put in the
month and the money but the other switch
is up here okay I don't know if that
that has to be it it's just working you
okay wait wait wait wait so
theoretically the water came in a window
break and you can go through there is it
where is the laser thing that you were
telling me about ended up here it's not
up here there's items up here I'm glad
you're with me now I need you to
understand first of all I'm going to I'm
saying I've wonder if one of those
windows broke and we just didn't see it
that's what the water get it's here you
[ __ ] little you just want above the
lasers I wonder now with the water it
doesn't make any goddamn sense like I
can just try again but like I don't
remember where the first question lasers
are oh no I'm not inoculated it's really
stupid
don't get mad at me bunnies I you have
way more time than you think hitting the
lasers drought drained your health your
option I agree but what I'm saying is
this I can't I can't scan so I can't see
the laser so I have no idea what I'm
doing anyway they closed them as I walk
by one on the far right - it's I mean
it's obviously planned for me to go swim
through the laser it's what I'm saying
is like I there's no way out yeah you go
above them oh my god oh my god I hate
this far left oh I thought you're gonna
there's a [ __ ] tentacle in here yeah
ten thousand percent
Oh window over there right windows
everywhere you just go up god we're
overthinking it we definitely are
overthinking this game yeah [ __ ] - I got
out of this blood hole I have to okay
good
hi Jill yeah you're standing a little
close to man work it's neutral I got the
passcode it's personal faith what do you
say ouch right there
it's gonna be a boss fight yeah maybe
not I'm making a list checking it twice
[Laughter]
both of you been naughty so it was you
you attacked Eric Reid yeah I'll live it
up that's agreed yeah wait make the area
safe is your objective all right
it takes me a really long time to reload
I'd like to it's fun taking out their
legs
Oh
oh whoa whoa
oh I shouldn't you add their mouths are
first I shouldn't use that Magnum like
that that dude you said you're gonna
induce him on Mary Mary yeah I have a
box right here
Oh
got you
this can take a while
this area is clean up one of these dudes
yeah
oh [ __ ]
hard to can you climb not anymore
keeping it in ice it's a secret
it's just teeth it's not cuz the music
oh [ __ ]
I think those guys took down will get it
look at him just sitting calm and a TV
watching you
oh yeah he's just observing oh I kind of
oh [ __ ] I don't have get down and watch
your help
do I have any help anywhere oh yeah just
use a Magnum you don't want to redo this
[ __ ]
Oh
oh [ __ ] yeah
you got like those grenades - oh great
okay that's our pulse I don't know how
to switch I'm down
I think like even a slight breeze could
take me down right now stay down
oh my god these guys are [ __ ] super
annoying [ __ ] yeah don't from a
distance oh my god I'm so tired shoot a
thousand now you know I shoot a thousand
I'll suck bullet [ __ ] oh god I can't
afford to miss right now that's all I'm
doing
stop moving convinced
hey hey
okay
who's this dude she's so movie oh I'm
gonna tease a magnum now you got him
with nothing to spare back for the help
Chris could really use a health right
now
hey what's you looking at there's
something down to bottom the ladder
maybe it's on the other side of the
pillar or something
check it out we're in the water that 100
he was there just couldn't climb a
ladder can you [ __ ] idiot yeah there
you go wow they really use all your
hammer there [ __ ] I did not think it
could be done all my little elves dying
well I could really use more than one
percent that was a chapter I think
anyway that's that's your weakness fear
welcome to the club I don't get chances
keep bones
he's got cue balls ooh nope that's the
Sumeria or whatever how did you know
maybe he's [ __ ] with you sweet nice
three more chapters yay did you did you
did
[Music]
whatever well the ending there you go
racking up those trophies for me intro
slide
[Music]
that went not bad aside from the lasers
though lasers actually went better than
they could have I was brilliant owing um
I am a I did not handle the lasers very
well but I didn't die
well actually I did die from drowning I
died once from drowning but I think
overall I felt like I executed that
fairly well yeah I'm cool pleased with
my work as usual we will almost
definitely be back next weekend where
you what can you talk about where you're
going this week like for work I'm going
to Georgia to do another setup of a
streamer all right I cannot go to
Oklahoma or say oh well ha but I will
tweet about it and it is actually by the
time this airs but anyway I still can't
say anything anyway you can check it out
he should be going live on Thursday cool
well as always we'll be back next
Saturday and enjoy the rest of your
Saturday or Sunday or whenever you
happen to be watching this
coming up on the holidays ish 10 is
coming up yeah we start our meeting soon
but either way I think you everybody for
stopping by
what does everybody know you what you
love don't tell my cats I got this
before I had cats and now I'm a cat
person I like dogs a lot too anyway yeah
whatever I've owned both what I have had
experience owning so I'm not had but no
we men say that no it thought you said I
boned both had you said I've owned ok
doesn't matter
inappropriate marry boned yes you do
this every time we talk about dogs and
cats you mistake us doing it with them